now if you were going to have cosmetic
surgery would you do your research
beforehand on the surgeon performing
well only a quarter of people survey
said that they would in a new report out
morning that thousands could be at risk
of a botched body so just how safe is
cosmetic surgery these days joining me
to discuss this is patient safety
campaigner Peter Walsh and these
findings saying that people are
recklessly rushing into what effectively
are serious procedures their operations
and it's so readily available in terms
of options and pricings now people see
it as going like going for a facial or
going to their hair dyed yes we're
talking about a burgeoning multi-million
pound industry and what's disappointing
is sometimes the way that these
treatments are are marketed to people is
actually preying on people's
vulnerability at a very difficult time
for them personally it's a huge decision
to make to undergo any form of surgery
especially when it's not strictly
necessary and so it's really important
that people think carefully about
whether they really want it and they
fully understand all of the risks
associated with the surgery because any
surgery carries risks considering it is
still a growing industry and as you said
it's a multi-million pound industry and
statistics say that one in four people
don't do their research properly yeah
that's true and we've had people come to
my charity who've suffered as a result
of substandard cosmetic surgery and
other cosmetic treatments it can be
life-changing devastating for people and
they have the double whammy really of
feeling a sense of guilt they blame
themselves because perhaps they hadn't
done their research beforehand it's
really really important that people
insist on a thorough discussion with
their consultant to understand all the
risks as well as the potential benefits
and that they check on the credentials
of the surgeon who's going to operate on
them they should check for example that
they're on a specialist register at the
GMC or that they're a member of one of
these
associations for esthetic and plastic
surgeons far too often we hear from
people who haven't done their homework
and have very sad unsatisfactory results
so the unit's very much being on the
patient here in the person who wants to
have the surgery undertaken but I was
quite surprised to find out that the
Royal College of Surgeons have done a
lot of research into this and they say
they want a new system to certify
surgeons for each procedure and for it
to be in their own field because some
surgeons operate outside their area of
expertise they also suggest a register
of certified surgeons to help the public
make an informed decision about the
quality of their surgeon I'm surprised
that these aren't already in place
considering the size of the industry yes
we are very disappointed that there
isn't better regulation of the cosmetic
industry people have been calling for it
for years in fact there's been two
high-profile reports produced by the
Department of Health itself most
recently by Sir Bruce Keogh the medical
director for NHS England at the end of
2013
progress on implementing these
recommendations is painfully slow and
whilst that goes on patients are left at
unnecessary risk for example it
shouldn't be possible for providers of
cosmetic surgery to market to advertise
their procedures offering cash
inducements two-for-one deals etc or in
ways that trivialize what is a really
important decision for the individual
there needs to be tougher checkups on
the providers of health service to make
sure that they're getting proper
informed consent from patients before
they treat them and one of the biggest
problems we encounter with private
treatment across the board but that
includes cosmetic treatment is a lack of
follow-up so you have your surgery done
there are complications it then can be
very difficult to have follow-up
monitoring and corrective treatment and
that's a loophole that desperately needs
to be plugged
you mentioned advertising there and I
know that the Advertising Standards
Authority have clamped down on a number
of ads that are trivializing and things
like boob jobs and
those jobs they've clamped down on that
but there needs to be some sort of
regulation on what seems to be a price
war as the industry grows surgeons seems
to be competing on price you do see
people traveling abroad for cheaper
treatment in Thailand for example
thousands of people from Australia the
United States England travel there for
cheaper surgery and also you get things
like I mean I get a lot of spam emails
from people like Groupon advertising
discounts for cosmetic surgery yes it's
it's very dispiriting to see that sort
of trivialization of what a potentially
life-changing decision for people and
that's one of many improvements to the
regulation of the industry that we want
to see another one really is about
empowering the patient now you have to
appreciate that some not all but some
people who are choosing to undergo
cosmetic treatment are themselves
vulnerable at that time they need to be
supported in making an informed decision
and one of the things that isn't present
in the private sector where the vast
majority of cosmetic treatment takes
place is a proper system of support and
independent advice for people if things
do go wrong in some places where it's
done badly it's a murky industry lacking
in transparency people don't know about
their rights they don't know how to
complain or to get safety concerns
looked into at a hospital or clinic
where they've been treated and they
haven't got that guarantee as an NHS
patient would have of independent help
and support and advice with their
complaint often people find it difficult
to find their way to us as a specialist
charity so all of this needs to be
addressed and if we empowered the
patient that's one part of the jigsaw
but you also need rigorous regulation of
the industry itself okay Peter I just
want to bring in Sarah bird she's a
multiple time plastic surgery patient so
he's well placed to speak about this
from a patient's point of view and Sarah
how much research did you do before
undertaking your cosmetic surgery good
morning to you firstly I think we need
to take a step back from all this
I mean what's actually
now is that people are using their face
and their bodies as sort of a fashion
statement and if they're not happy with
something and the fashions changed and
they literally want to throw it away and
go and get a new one now I'm not saying
that that's a good or a bad thing
but if we follow the right and correct
path to plastic surgery I really don't
see that that's the problem
now I've just been listening in on your
debate with them Peter I believe good
morning to you Peter and I do believe
that everyone needs to follow the
correct path although saying that I
receive on average 32 thousand female
'he's a year from people who are
dissatisfied with their body and the way
that they look now this is leading to
them going underground sourcing out the
voodoo witch doctors as I so call them
the botched up surgery going abroad
cheaper options discounts two for one
get one free that sort of thing but if
it's done correctly and the surgeon is
registered and he's a specialist in his
field then that really matters not we're
also looking at this from a
psychological point of view you
mentioned the thousands of emails you
get with people that are unhappy with
their body so it's not just a physical
ailment they feel it's psychological as
well even if you go to the best surgeon
there is are you is your aftercare
provided not just medically but
psychologically as well because it's a
big change to your body yes I mean
medically of obviously there's always an
element of risk I mean plastic surgery
isn't an exact science and it never will
be unfortunately but we have to minimize
the risk for instance we source out the
most reputable surgeon for the job
that's why I operate one of the largest
referral services in the world today and
also we minimize the risks by perhaps
not having a general anaesthetic and
opting for the local anesthetic because
the majority of surgery can be carried
out under a local anaesthetic these days
because we're so far advanced
so future patients are coming to people
like you for advice how disappointed are
you that there isn't some kind of a
your body official register somewhere
patients can go to to get official
sanction for who they're going to see
you know we seem to have lost Sarah
there we'll come back to when when we've
got better communications with it and
but Peter just wants to come back to you
what would your advice be to people who
regardless of the risks one cosmetic
surgery and are gonna go ahead with a
procedure where should they start doing
their research well they should make
sure that the provider they're speaking
to gives them the full information both
about the risks as well as the potential
benefits all too often what we see
touted is the potential good outcomes
from cosmetic surgery and there are good
outcomes but every surgery carries with
it risk and that needs to be fully
explained to people we'd recommend that
they take a family member or a friend
along to them with the consultation most
importantly they check on the
credentials both of the institution the
clinic or the hospital where they're
going to be treated and also of the
individual surgeon are they on a
specialist register for the kind of
procedure that they're proposing
undertaken have they done a lot of these
procedures how how many do they do in a
year what's their success rate and
another check people can make is whether
they're a member of one of the two
specialist associations for plastic and
then aesthetic surgeons but even a good
surgeon can go bad if something does go
wrong with a procedure like this there's
a certain stigma attached isn't it if
you've had cosmetic surgery it's not
life-threatening a lot of patients won't
know their rights will be too
embarrassed to follow it up and what
rights do they have Peter well they have
a right to make a complaint for example
all these organizations should be
regulated by the Care Quality Commission
and are required to have a complaints
procedure but private patients
unfortunately don't have the full rights
that an NHS patient would have for
example there's no final independent
arbitration in the sense of an ombudsman
which any of us who are NHS patients
would have and people aren't as
routinely to
told about places they can get
independent advice and support such as
my charity now that's where the
regulator's could be more robust in
insisting that people get information to
inform their decision whether or not to
have the surgery in the first place
so that they know about the risks and
they have a cooling-off period
before they actually undertake the
surgery but also when things go wrong
there needs to be a proper system of
redress and people need to be given
details of where they get advice and
information about their rights okay
Peter I'll leave the final word to Sarah
Sarah you've had a number of procedures
done and you're happy with the work
you've had done you've been very lucky
with the treatment you've had what would
your advice be to anyone sitting at home
thinking about having cosmetic surgery
well I mean plastic surgery actually
saved my life because if I didn't have
plastic surgery many years ago when I
was beaten to a pulp and my face was
rearranged for me I would have either
became a crazed alcoholic or I would
have topped myself and this is many of
the letters I receive with this content
in that because they can't get the
plastic surgery that they need because
they can't afford it and the NHS won't
supply it to them they're actually
having suicidal thoughts now as much as
I agree with what Peters saying a lot of
people are in so much of a hurry to and
so desperate I mean we're really talking
desperate going to desperate measures to
source out any way and means of having
the surgery that they think that they
need okay Sarah Burge Peter Walsh thank
you for talking to us here on Sky News
this morning thank you